[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا لنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما ابعاد استمرار المستوطنين
المتطرفين باستفزاز المقدسيين المصلين
داخل المسجد الاقصى من خلال اقتحامه
وادائهم طقوسا تلمديه والغناء والرقص في
بحته
وكيف ينعكس استمرار الدعم الرسمي من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لهذه الاقتحامات على
المشهد في القدس والضفه الغربيه من خلال
توفير الحمايه للمتطرفين ومشاركه شخصيات
رسميه حاليه وسابقه في مثل هذه الاقتحامات
واخيرا مر سائل من تحذير حركه حماس من
استمرار الاقتحامات وما خيارات وفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في المرحله المقبله
وكيف نقرا المواقف الامريكيه من استمرار
الاستفزازات الاسرائيليه للمقدسيين وكيف
تؤثر على جهود واشنطن في تح الاستقرار
والسلام في المنطقه كما تعلن عن ذلك
باستمرار
[موسيقى]
اذا في فصل جديد من اقتحامات المستوطنين
لباحات المسجد الاقصى وفرت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه لحمايه المشدده للمئات منهم
ممهده الطريق امامهم بافراغ الاقصى من
المصلين والاعتداء عليهم ما مكن اولئك
المستوطنين من دخول باحات المسجد واداء
طقوس تلمديه وترديد ترانيم والقيام برقصات
بدت اقرب الى وجبه استفزاز لعلها تقود الى
ردود فعل فلسطينيه ليجد المشهد نفسه مره
اخرى في دوامه التوتر المتصاعد الى موجه
جديده من العنف وكانت ما تسمى منظمات
الهيكل المزعوم دعت منذ ايام المستوطنين
الى تنفيذ اقتحامات واسعه لباحات الاقصى
بذريعه احياء راس السنه العبريه هذه المره
خطوه لم تمر دون ردود فعل فلسطينيه فلقد
اعتبرتها الخارجيه الفلسطينيه دليلا على
تماد اسرائيل ارتكابي مزيد من الجرائم
مستفيده في ذلك من الافلات من العقاب حركه
المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس اكدت من جانبها
ان الشعب الفلسطيني موحد في الدفاع عن
المسجد الاقصى ومواجهه ما وصفته بالعدوان
وشددت حماس على ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ستستمر حتى زوال الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
الاثناء اعلن مستشار البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن سيلتقي بنيامين
نتنياهو على هامش الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده في نيويورك الاربعاء دون الاشاره
الى ما اذا كانت هذه المحادثات ستشمل تلك
التطورات
[موسيقى]
لمناقشات هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام
الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن واشنطن
ينضم الينا دكتور ادوارد جوزف استاذه
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جونز هابكنز
اهلا بكما ابدا معك دكتور مصطفى يعني نسخه
جديده اذا من اقتحامات المستوطنين لباحات
المسجد الاقصى ما الذي يجب ان نتوقف عنده
هذه المره هل هناك نقطه بعينها
الذي يجب ان يتم التوقف على عنده ان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تقوم بدعم كل ما يجري
بكل طاقتها بل ان الذين يقتحمون المسجد
الاقصى هم ليسوا فقط متطرفين عنصريين من
جماعات الهيكل المزعوم وغيره بل الوزراء
انفسهم واعضاء في البرلمان الاسرائيلي
لانه لم يعد هناك حدود على الاطلاق بين
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبين المستعمرين
المستوطنين هم انفسهم في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وهم انفسهم متنفذين من خلال
والتحيه كل التحيه في الواقع للمرابطين
والمرابطات في ساحات المسجد الاقصى وخاصه
اهالي القدس البواسل الذين يتصدون بكل ما
يملكون باجسادهم بعقولهم بكل ما يملكون
لهذه الاقتحامات التي ترمي الى احداث
تقسيم زماني ومكاني في المسجد الاقصى الذي
يحدث هو محاوله احداث تراكم تراكم الى خلق
واقع جديد كما فعلوا في الحرم الابراهيمي
في الخليل الذي اغلقوه اليوم وامس امام
المصلين الفلسطينيين هم يحاولوا ان يكرروا
نفس الشيء بفرض وجود يهودي ووجود تهويدي
داخل المسجد الاقصى وهذه هي الخطوره وهذا
ما امل ان يراه المطبعين مع اسرائيل ان
يراه المطبعون مع اسرائيل كيف تقوم
اسرائيل بهذه الجرائم ليس فقط ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني بل بكل هذا القمع الديني للشعب
الفلسطيني وللمسلمين بشكل عام ولهاء لواحد
من اهم المقدسات الاسلاميه في المنطقه
وماذا عن ما تراه واشنطن دكتور ادوارد
جوزف كيف تنظر واشنطن لهذه النسخه الجديده
من الاقتحامات باي عين تنظر اليها وفي اي
سياق تضعها
انا لست متاكد بان واشنطن اداره تصدر كلمه
اقتحام ولا اعتقد انه يستعمله حتى هذه
الكلمه واعتقد ان الطريق نظرا اداره بايدن
الموضوع هو ذلك كله في سياقه وفعلين تذكر
هنا نحن في عالمين في الكثير من الناس
يعيشون من الاديان المختلفه وبهدف السلام
الهدف هؤلاء الناس هو احترام بعضهم الاخر
واحترام كل دين على حدا
وهذا ينطبق على القدس التي هي مقدسه
للمسلمين ولا اليهود والمسيحيين
وبالتالي لابد قلنا نوع من التوافق وبعض
الاحترام المتبادل حسب راي اهلنا المصطلح
الصحيحي هنا الذي
هو هذا المصطلح وطبعا هناك اجراءات لتحقيق
ذلك الاحترام
متبادل فان الاردنيين او الوقف الاردني
لديه صلاحيه
تنظيم او العمل في مسجد الاقصى وعلينا
نذكر ان هذه المجال مجال القدس هو ايضا
مقدس لليهود مقدس لكل اليهود اثناء السنه
الجديده ولكن ليست اسرائيليه تسيطر وتشغل
مسجد الاقصى بل وقف الاردني اما اسرائيل
فايت تسيطر على الامن والدخول وهذا محدود
فلا يسمح لليهود الصلاه هناك
اذا سمحت يعني
اذا سمحتي تتحدث عن احترام متبادل هل تدخل
ضمنها هذه الصلوات التلموديه والترانيم
ويعني هذه المشهديه التي فيها استفزاز
للمكان وللمسلمين في هذا التوقيت ونعرف ما
جرت اليه مثل هذه الاعمال في السابق فاذا
كان هناك فعلا رغم في احترام متبادل اين
هو الاحترام الجانب اليه ود هنا
السؤال هو طبعا هو ان الشرطه الاسرائيليه
اعتقلت واوقفت اليهود حتى هذا اليوم جرى
اعتقال اليهود قبل الشرطه الاسرائيليه
التي قال في القواعد والقانون قوانين
دقيقه وهي لصالح المسلمين بشكل كبير وانا
اكرر ان قانون او شروط الدخول
المزلق سوما يصبح الناس سيقوم به داخل
المسجد الاقصى وهي لصالح المسلمين بشكل
كبير اذ يسمح للمسلمين صلاته هناك وهذه
موجب قبوله اسرائيل لهذه القواعد التي
يتفق معها مع الاردن حولها يسمح للمسلمين
الصلاه ولكن لا يسمح لليهود الصلاه واذا
ما انتهك اليهود هذه هذه القواعد كم
حصلناها هناك ثلاثه هيود اعتقلتهم الشرطه
وهذه يدل على الاحترام المتبادل وطبعا
فكرتك في هذه الاثناء الدكتور مصطفى يهز
راسه بضراوه اين هو موضع الخلاف يعني
الاحترام المتبادل خصوصا انا هدى مثلا بين
المقتحمين والشرطه الاسرائيليه توفر
الحمايه فما نوع الرابط هنا هل هو الدعم
ام تبني من الحكومه الاسرائيليه لما يجري
اخت ليلى انا اعتقد ان ضيفك الامريكي اما
انه جاهل او يعني مضلل يريد ان يضلل
الجمهور بكلامه الفارغ اي احترام للمسلمين
نحن ممنوعون من الوصول للمسجد الاقصى اكثر
من 95% من الشعب الفلسطيني في الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه ممنوعون من الوصول الى
المسجد الاقصى انا ممنوع من الدخول الى
القدس منذ عام 2005 واذا دخلنا ندخل عنوه
ورغم انفهم هذا الذي يجري ظلم كبير
المسلمون والمسيحيون الفلسطينيون ممنوعون
من حريه الوصول لاماكن الصلاه سواء في
المسجد الاقصى او في كنيسه القيامه او في
الاماكن الاخرى هل يسمح لنا ان نذهب الى
المكان الذي يصلي فيه اليهود مثلا هل اذا
اردت ان اذهب هناك يسمحون لي بذلك باي حق
يدخل الى ساحات المسجد الاقصى ومن قال ان
لليهود حق في المسجد الاقصى هذا تبني كامل
للروايه الاسرائيليه
الاسرائيلي جنود الاسرائيليون اليوم بطشوا
بالمرابطات والمرابطين واعتدوا على النساء
وانتم اظهرتم ذلك على شاشتكم فهذا الذي
يجري نوع من الكلام المضلل وكلام غير صحيح
وفي غير مكانه ولا يجب ان يسمح به الذي
يجري حقيقه ان هناك اضطهاد سياسي واضطهاد
عنصري واضطهاد قومي واضطهاد ديني للشعب
الفلسطيني وهذا ما لا نقبل به ولولا
مقاومه الشعب الفلسطيني الباسله ولولا
بساله المرابطين والمرابطات ولولا رساله
اولئك الذين قدموا حياتهم واصبحوا شهداء
في الدفاع عن المسجد الاقصى والاف الجرحى
الذين وقعوا وهم يدافعون عن عن سلامه
المسجد الاقصى لتم تهويده بالكامل الذي
يجري عمليه تزوير للتاريخ تزوير للروايه
ومحاوله لفرض واقع جديد بمفاده بما في ذلك
ضب وتبويض القدس فرصه للدكتور ليعلق على
هذه النقطه يبدو ان هناك روايه اسرائيليه
تتبناها الولايات المتحده ومن ضمنها ليس
فقط المسؤولون ولكن ايضا المفكرون
والمحللون الى اي حد فعلا الصوره واضحه
بالنسبه لكم في الولايات المتحده بشان ما
يجري على الارض فيما يتعلق بالمسجد الاقصى
والاقتحامات الجارحه حاليا
ان يستخدموا كل العبارات والمصطلحات
الاستفزازيه اذا ما شاؤوا السيد برغوثي ان
كان يدعي بان كل هذا جزء من سرديه كبير
حول معاناه الفلسطينيين لكن مع الاسف
بالنسبه له هذه حقائق هناك حقائق والحقائق
لا يمكن الخلاف حولها وهذا هو حسب رايه
طريقه نظر لاداره بايدن للموضوع انا اكرر
هذا موضوع في غايه الحساسيه وموجب
الحساسيه
مع السيد برغوثي هي قضيه يعني يشاهدها
الجميع اذا سمحت
تتكلم ساقاطعك اريدك ان تسمعني الان يعني
هي ليست قضيه دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي هي
قضيه نشاهدها جميعا على شاشات التلفزيون
ولا اقصد هنا الشاشات العربيه انما
الشاشات العالم لمن في الواقع يرغب في نقل
الصوره الحقيقيه نشاهد مصلين يتم الاعتداء
عليهم نشاهد مصلين يمنعون من اداء الصلاه
نشاهد مصلين يتم استفزازهم بطريقه ممنهجه
يعتدى عليهم بالضرب فكيف يمكن ان
نغطي الشمس بغربال كما يقولون
لا استطيع ان
اعلق على تغطيتكم لهذا الموضوع هذا ليس من
واجبي التحدث امام تختاره وقناتكم ان
تعرضه هذا الامر يعود لكم انتم تقدرون
وتعرضونه لكن تبقى الحقيقه والحقائق انه
رغم ان اسرائيل لديه سيطره كامله على
المنطقه المحيطه بمسجد الاقصى الا ان لا
تسمح لليهود بالصلاه هناك كثير من اليهود
مستاءون من ذلك وهذه حقيقه
السيد مرغوثي تقولوا ما تشاءان وانا هذا
صحيح وانا ساتحدث بشكل مباشر الى مشاهديكم
الحقيقه في كل شيء اقولها كل الشرق الاوسط
فقط ويسمح للمسلمين الصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى بامكانكم التاكد ذلك من الوقف
الاردني اللي هو المسؤول واي شيء اخر تسمع
عنه غير صحيح اي شيء اخر تسمعه غير صحيح
وفقط المسلمون يسمح لهم بالصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى لا هذه النقطه تحديدا حتى ننهي
الموضوع بهذه النقطه وننتقل الى نقطه اخرى
تفضل
اذا بحكي عن الاحترام والمساواه انا بساله
هل يسمح لي او لاي فلسطيني اخر ان نذهب
للصلاه في مكان صلاه اليهود المكان الذي
يصلون فيه هم باي حق يريد ان يدخلوا الى
مكان صلاتنا والى المسجد الاقصى ومن قال
ان لهم حق صلاه هناك اين التكافؤ هذا كلام
مضلل وكلام غير صحيح وللاسف هاي الاداره
الامريكيه كل ما فعلته منذ جاء بايدن
للحكومه لم تفعل شيء واحد من اجل مناصره
الحق الفلسطيني هل ضم القدس التي هي ارض
محتله يعتبر مقبولا بالقانون الدولي الم
تضم اسرائيل القدس وتقوم بعمليه تهويد لها
هذا هل هذا مقبول في القانون الدولي
وهل من المقبول ان تنشر اسرائيل
المستعمرات الاستيطانيه في اراضي محتله
وما ينص عليه القانون الدولي وقرار مجلس
الامن اثنين ثلاثه اربعه الذي مرروا في
زمنه اوباما ولم يعترض عليه ينص على ان
الشيطان غير شرعي وغير قانوني كيف يمكن ان
يسمح بذلك لم تفعل اداره بايدن حتى اليوم
الا محاوله الضغط على دول عربيه كالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وغيرها لكي تطبع مع
اسرائيل وهي حتى الان تفشل في ذلك والحمد
لله هل قامت بشيء واحد نصره للفلسطينيين
هل تجرات على فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في
القدس مثلا لم تفعل ذلك ولن تتجرا على ذلك
هل اعادت فتح مكتب منظمه التحرير مثلا
وهذا شيء بسيط جدا ابدا لماذا تصنف منظمه
التحرير حتى اليوم الى جانب كل القوى
الفلسطينيه الاخرى كانها منظمات ارهابيه
الذي نراها انحياز مطلق وضيفك يكرر هذا
الانحياز بتبني الروايه الاسرائيليه
الكامله وتبنيه للروايه الاسرائيليه لا
يجعلها حقيقه الحقيقه ما نقوله نحن وليس
ما يقوله هو طيب على العموم يعني انا اريد
ان فقط اوسع دائره النقاش لان هذه النقطه
واضح ان هناك يعني رؤيه مختلفه عند
الدكتور ادوا الجوزف ولكن فقط نقطه فيما
يتعلق بالتغطيه يعني هي ليست التغطيه التي
نتعمد نحن ابرازها ولكن هي التغطيه ربما
التي يتعمد الطرف الاخر عدم ابرازها وهنا
ربما جوهر القضيه واريد ان اسالك في
الجانب السياسي يعني المنطقه متوتره جدا
هذه الافعال الى اي حد يعني تصب الزيت على
النار تشعل
عود الثقاب من جديد في مرحله جدا حساسه ما
الذي يمكن ان تفعله الولايات المتحده ايضا
وهي تراقب المشهد لوضع حد لهذا التوتر
انك سؤالك رائع فؤاد ما ينبغي يجب ان
نتحدث عنه علينا ان نتحدث فعلا عن طرق
تخفيف التوتر وليس زيادتها عن طريق ولم
نسمع من يفندد نقطه حول الحقائق والحقائق
انه فقط المسلمون فقط يسمح لهم سجاد في
الاقصى ولكن مصدر التوتر نتذكر انه عندما
نتحدث عن توترات والعنف والقلق والقتل في
الشرق الاوسط ننظر الى الحرب الموجوده في
البلد المجاور في سوريا منذ عقود تطبيقات
الالاف من السوريين قد قدوا مئات الالاف
قتلوا
وبالتالي مره اخرى انا لا يمكن ان اعلق
على تغطياتكم وانا متاكد انه غطيتو هذه
الحرب السوريه بشكل جيد لكن لكن قلق حول
المعاناه في الشرق الاوسط فينبغي ان
تركزوا على بشار الاسد وعلى ايران وتركز
على الحروب
ستخرجنا باطار هذه الحلقه انا اتحدث الان
عن توتر حاصل في باحات المسجد الاقصى من
الطرف الاسرائيلي واقول لك دكتور مصطفى ان
هذا يحصل يعني بضوء اخضر على ما يبدو
للمستوطنين من جانب نتنياهو يستندون الى
هذا الضوء الاخضر والسؤال الى ماذا يستند
نتنياهو في كونه يامن العقاب من ما يجري
حاليا برايك
السؤال دكتور مصطفى تفضل
نتنياهو يرتكز الى امرين الامر الاول انه
يقود حكومه عنصريه يمنيه متطرفه
وينفذ مشروع هو الذي خطط له مشروع القضاء
على امكانيه قيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
وحره مشروع ضم وتهويد الضفه الغربيه
ويستخدم الان الفاشيون من امثال سموترش
الذين يسمون انفسهم فاشيين
لتنفيذ ذلك بشكل واسع وواضح ويستند ايضا
الى حقيقه ان الولايات المتحده وليس فقط
الولايات المتحده كل الحكومات الغربيه
عاجزه وعن ان تقوم بفرض عقوبه واحده على
اسرائيل على خرقها للقانون الدولي عاجزه
عن ان تقوم بفرض عقوبه واحده على توسيع
الاستيطان الاجرامي عاجزه عن ان تقوم بفرض
عقوبه واحده على خرق اسرائيل للقانون
الدولي على مدار الساعه وكل يوم وبالتالي
هو يستند الى كل ذلك وللاسف الشديد دعيني
اقول انه يستند الى حقيقه ان بعض الحكومات
وعلى عكس اراده شعوبها قامت بالتطبيع مع
هذا النظام الفاشل وقامت بالتطبيع مع هذه
مع هذا الكيان المعتدي والمحتل وبالتالي
هو يتشجع بذلك انما في نهايه المطاف ما
يفشل نتنياهو وما سيفشل نتنياهو ويفشل كل
الداعمين له هو شيء محدد واضح وواحد وواحد
مقاومه وصلابه واصرار الشعب الفلسطيني
الذي راينا اروع صورها في وقفه المرابطين
والمرابطات اليوم في المسجد الاقصى دكتور
ادويه في الواقع يعني المشهد يتكرر وفي كل
مره يبدو ان حكومه اثنتنياهو يعني غير
قلقه من اي محاسبه لا يهمها من تغضب حتى
وان كان ساكن البيت الابيض نفسه فالسؤال
كيف يمكن لاي مسار
تهدئه او تسويه ان يتقدم بالفعل على هذه
الخلفيه
ان نتنياهو لديه قلق كثير حول التعرض
لمحاسبه مسائله حتى في داخل اسرائيل حيث
يقضى حاليا الاحتياجات كبيره مستمره منذ
اشهر اتجاهات كبيره في بلد ديمقراطي نجد
في ان الاحتجاجات مسموحه ولكن لست متاكده
من حيث يعيش السيد برغوثي هل ان
الاحتجاجات الكبيره مسموح بها مثلا ضد
الرئيس عباس الذي هو في سلط رغم انه خسر
الانتخابات منذ سنوات
ولدينا قلق شديد في الولايات المتحده حول
الحكومه اليمينيه في اسرائيل وقد وصفها
الرئيس بايدن من اكثر حكومه يمينيه وهي
واشنطن غير سعيده
توسع
المستعمره المستوطنات
ويدعو الى حل حل الدولتين الذي وحل عادل
الشعب الفلسطيني وايضا مفيد
واستقراض الشعب الاسرائيلي السيد فايدان
هناك دول اخرى اوضحت ذلك وهذا يبقى هو
الهدف النهائي ولكن طبعا السيد البرغوث لا
يتحدث عن الانقسامات داخل بالداخل المجتمع
الفلسطيني نفسه
موجود على الارض هناك وهو يرقب ربما بشكل
مباشر ما يجري اذا سمحت فقط واريد ان
اسالك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي عن الخيارات
الان الخيارات المطروحه امام المقاومه
امام الفصائل امام السلطه باختصار شديد
يعني سؤال كبير ولكن باختصار شديد لو سمحت
باختصار شديد اولا ضيفك فعلا يكرر كل ما
يقوله الاسرائيليون وواضح انه مناصر بشكل
كامل لهم ولكن انا معارض للسلطه ديمقراطيه
ولا احد يمنعني من الكلام ونحن عرضنا منع
الانتخابات في فلسطين ونؤكد على ضروره
اجراءها ولكن سؤالي لماذا الولايات
المتحده ضد ان تجري انتخابات ديمقراطيه في
فلسطين
ولماذا اسرائيل ضد ان يمارس الشعب
الفلسطيني حقه في الانتخابات الديمقراطيه
ان كانوا يتحدثون عن الديمقراطيه والسؤال
الاهم عندما نقوم نحن بمظاهرات ماذا يفعل
الجيش الاسرائيلي بنا نحن اطلق الرصاص
علينا من قبل جيش الاحتلال مره تلو الاخرى
حتى المظاهرات الشعبيه التي ذات طابع سلمى
يقوم الرصاص عليها كما فعلوا اليوم كما
فعلوا اليوم في قطاع غزه
العديدين بمن فيهم صحفي ستبقى معلقه
ولكنها محمله بكثير من الرسائل اشكرك
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي من رام الله واشكر
من واشنطن الدكتور ادوارد جوزيف واشكركم
ايضا مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر فيما لا
[موسيقى]